we are back with part two of our series
reacting to a lady named aaron who is a
nurse who is pro-abortion and has gone
viral trying to tutor pro-abortion
people on how to make more persuasive
arguments to convince pro-lifers in her
first video
she didn't really
make any arguments for abortion she just
pointed out which arguments for abortion
were not going to work for pro-lifers
and there she was basically right
pro-lifers legitimately think abortion
is murder the facts and logic both of
them in this video are brought to you by
good ranchers more from them in just a
second first though let's get to more of
this lady's arguments okay that video
got popular so let me just set something
straight you're not going to convince
them in a single conversation
what you need to do though is you need
to validate them if you continue to
disregard the fact that a fetus is a
whole person in their eyes they're going
to shut you out like you're already an
immoral person because you are not
seeing that fetus as a human being it's
not necessarily the case that the
pro-abortion people making these
arguments that babies aren't really
babies that they're necessarily immoral
i mean what what they are doing is
immoral but they they might not be
morally culpable as much because they
might just be ignorant they might just
not realize it the reason that
pro-lifers are going to disregard your
arguments if you pretend that the baby
isn't a baby is because they're going to
say oh you have no idea what you're
talking about
either you're just being obtuse or
you're sincerely ignorant and you i
don't know maybe you think the baby's a
platypus or a zebra maybe you think the
the obviously living baby that has all
the characteristics of life is not
living somehow but both of those points
are just so absurd i really shouldn't
take your argument seriously because the
premise you're beginning with is is
manifestly not true so that that's the
issue it's not even a moral judgment so
much as a rational judgment that the the
arguments that are being made are so
ridiculous that they're not worth
entertaining okay next one you first
need to validate that like i see your
concern like you see the heartbeat on
ultrasound you know you feel that
connection with that unborn child
as hard as it is you're going to have to
build that safe space to have that
conversation and again you're going to
have to in their eyes they see mom and
the fetus they see the fetus as a child
yeah we see the child as a child it's
funny the way she's talking to these
pro-abortion people i know it's going to
be really hard but you're going to have
to force yourself to view the baby
inside his mother's womb as a baby
inside his mother's womb i know it's so
crazy right you to imagine a child as a
child yes
you have to if you're going to begin to
try to argue with a pro-lifer and you
support abortion you're going to have to
accept
the most basic facts about what is going
on before you're going to have a
fruitful conversation that's true so if
you have a mom and a child
and you say well let's protect the mom
in real life most parents are going to
protect their child at all costs so they
think that you're just a bad parent if
you are not doing everything in your
power to protect your unborn fetus
because they see that as a child uh yes
it's true uh good parents protect their
kids at all costs absolutely true but
the premise here is also wrong
this lady aaron is presenting this uh
pregnancy as
a battle to the death between mother and
child
she's presenting pregnancy as some kind
of crisis some kind of emergency some
unusual thing it's not it's not a battle
it's not like there's just a pie of life
and the more baby gets the less mommy
gets that's that's actually the opposite
of what pregnancy is you're giving life
to your child and you are both
flourishing as a result of this this
woman seems to imply that maternal
mortality is extremely high it's not
it's extraordinarily low and as we
mentioned in the last video there are
risks to the mother from abortion too
think about kermit gosnell think about
the infamous abortionists in this
country who have killed women people die
and have all sorts of complications from
abortion you can't deny the pregnancy
one has to grapple with the pregnancy
the only question is you're going to
kill the baby or not kill the baby and
it's not a zero-sum game here okay it's
not the mommy and the baby are not
enemies okay the mommy and the baby are
mommy and baby all right and that's why
when she even points out she says most
people just think you should take care
of your baby yes that is natural that is
the right thing to do that is the good
thing to do and it's not going to hurt
mommy to take care of her baby
as a general rule of course
complications exist but that's that's
sort of a side point to the issue here
and the framing is just so
false this talking point i don't think
has fully convinced any pro-lifer but
this is something that really struck me
and that's the thing is every time you
talk to somebody who used to be pro-life
who is now pro-choice um there's their
situations are very very different like
what turned them into being pro-choice
one thing for me was when pro-lifers are
very set on the fact that
life begins at conception
what are the biological qualities that
that cause that
thing a life they say dna
that's that's not exactly true dead
bodies have dna but dead bodies are not
alive there are characteristics of life
i forget them off of the top of my head
but things such as growth for instance
things like metabolism there are agreed
upon characteristics of life i think the
number is seven that the scientific
community says these are the these are
the characteristics that define life the
little tiny baby even at the little
tiniest moment in the womb has those
characteristics just as much as a
two-month-old baby outside of the womb
in kind at least and just as much as a
five-year-old
person outside of the womb and so
when when pro-lifers say that life
begins at conception
we're we're making a a sort of
truism we're stating a truism here it
conception is the beginning so yes of
course the beginning of life is the
beginning it's not in the middle that's
why we call it conception
it's it's not merely because of dna
though it is true what is that dna well
the dna that comes together at the
moment of conception is it's not the dna
of the sperm it's not the dna of the egg
it is a new in-kind
type of dna that is fully human and
individual and distinct from the mother
that's true that's why the baby is an
individual and then the baby is alive
because the baby has the characteristics
of life there is so much more to get to
but first we've got to talk about my
great friends over good ranchers given
the major wins at the supreme court it
feels as though the pendulum may finally
be swinging back to a time when family
was at the heart of american life where
real conversation learning and growth
began at home with your family gathered
around the table president ronald reagan
famously said all great change in
america begins at the dinner table we'll
bring your family to the dinner table
with good ranchers these guys are the
best they ship 100 american meat born
raised and harvested in the united
states right to your door they age every
cut to perfection they give you the true
steakhouse experience right in your own
home the quality simply cannot be beat
when you subscribe i'm not joking your
price is locked in for life we're at a
time of crazy inflation going through
the roof and somehow you're going to
lock in your meat prices for life these
guys are wonderful i eat good ranchers
probably three times a week at this
point i love their products their
chicken their beef their burgers their
steaks all of it is so phenomenal use my
code null scanner wlas to get your
steakhouse experience for 30 bucks off
plus free shipping on your order
shipping is not cheap this is a lot of
top quality meat so take advantage of
this offer go to goodranchers.com
knowles these guys are the best start
bringing people back to the table and
eating seriously delicious food have you
already bought from good ranchers good
show me what you're making post a photo
of your meal tag me and my friends over
at goodranchers so they can see it too
make sure you go check out good ranchers
today you will thank me for it okay back
to this lady's arguments then you have
to say politely
when someone is on life support when
they are intubated
all the dna is there
then they're going to counter argue and
say well
the fetus has the potential for life now
she's either straw manning because i've
just made this point right now forget
about life support a dead body has dna
maybe she sincerely thinks that that's
what pro-lifers believe but that's
that's not a good argument there that
she's uh
she's burning down fields of straw men
so then you're going to say okay well if
i'm if i'm hearing you correctly you're
not actually saying a life is a life
because of dna you're saying a life is a
life because of the potential for life
no so even roe versus wade that that
decision describes the baby in the womb
as a potential life but that's not true
we're not saying that a life is a life
because it has the potential for life
that would be an incoherent statement
we're saying it the life is the life
because the the baby has the
characteristics of life not that he will
have them someday he has them from the
moment of conception it's less an
argument than an observation i'm just
describing something that that is true
the baby has those characteristics of
life that's why he
has the characteristics of life i always
use argument when my father was 52 had a
massive stroke and he was on life
support he had a heartbeat and he had
brain activity but pro-lifers will say
well his prognosis was really bad well
take a pause that's not true by the way
i'm i am i don't know about other
pro-lifers but all all the pro-lifers
that i do know myself included
we're not the most eager to pull people
off of life support now if people have
brain death for instance if people are
really just being animated by some
machines moving their rib cage up and
down or something then obviously the
person is
dead but if someone is in a coma or if
someone is having assisted breathing but
otherwise has
their life they still remain alive we're
not eager to pull them off of life
support just because the prognosis
doesn't look good
i i don't know where she got that from
but that that is not the way that
pro-life people think think about life
and death so then you again have to
objectively look at the situation and
respectfully say
okay this is your quality of life is
potential
and dna
some of them are going to say a
heartbeat or brain activity mostly most
are going to say heartbeat
and then you're going to say well i have
these other patients who meet all of
that criteria is it murder if i pull the
plug on somebody who meets all of the
criteria and if you're going to talk
about prognosis
there are many people in my dad's
situation who could have survived and
who did survive right that's what we're
saying don't
don't pull grandpa off of life support
if he's gonna make a recovery that's
crazy what pro-lifer would do that maybe
a pro-abortion person would do that
maybe aaron here would do that i would
not recommend doing that and there is
also a difference by the way when we're
talking about someone who is nearing the
end of their life 90 years old let's say
is on
some kind of medical interventions that
are becoming more and more dramatic more
and more extraordinary and the time they
have left is almost certainly very very
little and a little baby in the womb
there is a difference in how to look at
life none of us here gets out alive all
of us are going to die at some point and
the way we treat life and death for
someone approaching natural death is is
actually different than the way we
approach life and death for a little
baby who
psychos are going to snuff out into the
womb but it's almost beside the point
because
aaron's making my argument for me here
no the pro-lifers are not going to say
oh well he had a good life this hospital
bill it's getting a little bit expensive
here he'll make a recovery but i don't
know i got a tee time at noon so pull it
baby no none of us is going to do that
and if we're going to put god in that
situation and say it's up to god then
you need to recognize that it wasn't our
decision to care for him now i really
don't know what she's talking about
first of all we don't put god into
decisions god
god puts himself
into the created world and god is more
powerful than we are okay so if you're
saying well if we're going to rely on
our religious views
of
things that's true this woman and the
pro-abortion people are relying on the
religious view that life
is uh
not
intrinsically valuable and that uh the
the value of life is really up to our
own will and whims and capricious and
what we want to do with that that's a
religious view it's not not a good
religious view not a true religious view
we say thou shalt not commit murder you
know that that's our religious view
that's the traditional christian
religious view jewish muslim and that
one happens to be correct and if you're
saying well leave it up to god
uh it is true i guess a pro-life
position would
would be do not commit murder do do not
intervene in a person's life in that way
or hasten their their death
uh sure i i guess we shouldn't i guess
that but that argument just gets back to
the first one i guess what we're
debating is
should you be allowed to commit murder
if you want to or should you not be
allowed to commit murder if you want to
and
i just think that really it's a battle
between the will and the intellect i
guess she's saying well if i really want
to do it it's totally fine and i'm
saying no even even if you really want
to kill your baby
there is a moral reality that you can
access through your reason and you can
know that that's wrong and you have to
subordinate your will to that moral
reality
but you don't want to do that
[Music]
[Music]